public schools in loudoun county
virginia like so many schools
in this country have gone insane in the
last year they've essentially stopped
teaching instead they're indoctrinating
children with
creepy and poisonous racial theories
master race stuff
scary in loudoun county kids are not
allowed to read to kill a mockingbird
anymore instead they're assigned
pornographic novels and told that
america is an evil racist place
so parents in loudoun county have been
revolting against this not just right
wingers
by the way not just politically active
people people with kids in the schools
why would you want your kids taught some
bizarro
poisonous racial theory it's disgusting
so last night the school board met in
london county and agreed to solicit
public comments
they didn't take that many but those
they heard weren't very positive
the western culture and values that
brought forth christianity and the
founding documents
are being called evil and racist you're
not the captain we're your bosses and
god willing will return most of you to
the private sector very soon
i'm reminded of the tyranny of communist
china
where your money is legally stolen and
then used in government schools
not public schools these are not public
schools these are government schools
like here to indoctrinate children
against their parents
my child is not oppressed and don't
assume that
as long as you marxist push your
unconstitutional agenda
on my child she will not be returning
back to mountain county schools
[Applause]
so the school board didn't want to hear
it there's out of touch as
most of our institutions they didn't
want to hear it so they had the meeting
declared an unlawful assembly
one parent called judd tigus a man from
the community was
arrested watch this
and the county taxpayer pays your salary
you guys are actually supporting the
suppression of people's rights
are you refusing to leave at this time
yes i'm refusing
kids too deputies please arrest this
individual for trespassing
so they handcuffed him and dragged him
away didn't want to hear from him
apparently
john tickets joins us now to explain
what happened john thanks so much for
coming on if it feels like
this is in loudoun county is the place
and this is the moment where people have
just finally
just had it with these scary racial
theories
uh tell us what happened to you why did
they arrest you
that's a good question tucker because uh
as best i understand it i was in a place
that
where free speech has to happen if you
want to
redress your grievances about a school
board there's no other place you can do
it than in a
school board meeting and in this case we
went on to public land
went into a public auditorium
we were there for a public forum
that we were invited to and i was signed
up to give public
comment and at
the end of all that every single
person there all 500 parents had their
first amendment rights
trampled on by the loudoun county school
board and its superintendent
if they keep acting like this they're
going to get a revolution i mean this is
this is what happens when you ignore
legitimate
complaints is is people get radical and
i hope it doesn't happen but
you could see how it could so in this
case these are the people who pay for
loudoun county schools
the building was reserved and open until
7 00 p.m they arrested you before seven
as i understand
yeah actually it was closer to about 5
45
and we were supposed to go until seven
until
the school board heard something they
didn't like and
which was ironically applause for
one of the people that we were
supporting senator dick black
and the net result was they shut it down
but there was not violence there wasn't
crazy going on
people stayed there they actually
started singing and then
we just encouraged folks that if the
school board didn't want to hear it
we were going to hear from one another
and we allowed a very orderly
peaceful process of allowing people to
actually start speaking and they did
that they lined up
and peacefully started presenting their
perspectives and we
allowed the other side to do the same
and then suddenly it was declared an
unlawful assembly
after the thing that you're showing
right now occurred which as best i can
tell was a complete leftist diversionary
tactic that was pre-planned
because no one that was lined up to
speak
was involved in any of that so the net
result was
they declared an unlawful assembly and
then they moved
a whole series of pre-positioned
deputies and tried to push them out of
the room threatening them all with
arrest
so they didn't like what you had to say
so they declared your talking
illegal and then they got these stooge
cops who should be ashamed of themselves
to arrest you for the crime of saying
something the school board didn't like
that's not saying anything no you're not
missing anything and
and that's what's so infuriating is
there's such a high standard
for free speech you know it is the most
sacred of all of our
rights and it takes an amazing amount
of justification to shut down free
speech
yeah it does and and it's you know not
liking it is not
adequate justification i hope you keep
getting arrested john i'm i mean that
um because i i think only until people
are willing to be arrested for
exercising their constitutional rights
will those rights be protected so
i appreciate what you did and coming on
tonight thank you thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else